We have a nicely styled map,
we have some points.
Now, let's show our customers what
the listed properties look like.
Street View imagery,
is one of the awesome features of Google
Maps that's widely used and loved.
In case you don't know,
the word is big, really big.
You just won't believe how vastly,
hugely, mind bogglingly, big it is.
Street View imagery
is 360 degree imagery
of a huge number of locations
throughout the world.
The Google Maps APIs,
provide a service for obtaining and
manipulating the imagery used
in Google Maps Street View.
>> Now let's find out, how we can
get this imagery and show it in
the InfoWindow, so our users don't
have to drive around to each building.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> First, let's understand what
makes up a Street View panorama.
Obviously, we need to know
what place we're looking at.
For example, this is my favorite dessert
place in New York City, Rice to Riches.
They sell $7 rice pudding, but
it's totally worth it, believe me.
Next, we need the point of view.
Do we want to be looking at this
building from the east or the west?
This is called the heading.
Also, should we be looking down
on the building or up at it?
This is called the pitch.
We'll need to define these things
dynamically for each of our points.
Let's dive back into the code.
Okay, we're going to go back to our
populateInfoWindow function that
we created before.
This function needs to
do a few more things,
besides just creating a string
to put inside the InfoWindow.
The first thing we're
going to have it do is,
create a new streetViewService object.
This service needs to get the panorama
image based on the closest
location to the marker.
And it needs to find out which
way to point the camera,
the heading and the pitch.
Now, we could just create a panorama
object with the position of the exact
landmark of the market, but
what if there is no imagery for
that exact location?
Since we're smart, we're going to
define a radius of 50 meters,
that it's going to look for
a StreetView image within.
Now we are going to use the
streetViewService.getPanoramaByLocation
function and
pass in the position of the marker,
the radius and call our getStreetView
function, which we'll define above.
The getStreetView function,
is basically going to take that nearby
StreetViewLocation and compute a heading
based on the location of the nearest
StreetView and location of our marker.
In order to do this we're going to
use the google maps geometry library.
We're going to load the geometry
library when we load the API by using
the library's perimeter.
We'll talk more about this later.
This will allow us to use everything
within the geometry library.
In order to compute the correct heading,
so
that we're looking at our building
from the nearest StreetViewLocation,
we're going to use
the compute heading function.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
When we set our panoramaOptions,
we're going to tell it that it's in
the position of that nearest
StreetViewLocation and that the point
of view that we'll be using, is going to
be the heading that we just computed and
a pitch of 30, which is going to have
us looking slightly up at the building.
We're going to actually create
that panorama object and
put it inside the infowindow at
the div with the id of panel.
If no Street View image is found,
then we'll put information into
that info window indicating that.
Let's test it out, awesome.
Now we can show users, what their
future new digs will look like.
We've covered a bunch of
useful dynamic stuff so far.
But what if you just want to show
a simple image, a Street View or
a non dynamic map?
You can see the same Street View
imagery, we were just working with and
embed it in your site or
app just like any other image.
You can also use the Street View
functionality without a map.
You simply need to use
a URL as the image and
pass in the parameters
we just discussed.
The location, the heading and
pitch of the imagery and the size.
We can use this in any
image element in your page.
>> Similarly, if you just want to
display a simple non effective map.
You don't need to use the full
JavaScript API, you can use the static
maps API to do this more simply and it
will load more quickly for the end user.
For example,
if we wanted to show our users a list
view of our real estate listings,
they might benefit from a small
thumbnail view of where the location is.
We only need to create
a static map image URL and
specify a zoom level, center and
size and optionally define some markers,
info windows or other items, which will
also just be part of the image return.
>> To learn more check out
the link in the notes.
Let's take a short quiz on
the material we just went over and
then we'll move back to
the JavaScript functionality and
show some awesome ways you can create
geometric overlays on your map.